another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation dr bright no  taunting your future hosts dr bright is  a force of chaos that cannot be bound to  only one mortal form we all know this  his consciousness is contained in that  pretty little amulet around his neck  every so often like a hermit crab  changing its shell dr bright moves on  from his human host to take up residence  in a new flesh shell  anyway dr bright is not allowed to taunt  or harass his future hosts in any way  including telling them you're about to  become very bright saying possession is  nine tenths of the law or referring to  d-class personnel as extra lives you'll  never have a career in stand-up doctor